this is the Joo underground podcast
number 88 sitting here with Echo
Charles what's going on Eko you good
yeah good thank you decisive
Victory almost maybe you need to go and
post and put some sound effects behind
that maybe some like you know heroic
music yeah sure and I'll and put some
echo on my voice so it's like decisive
Victory sure cuz it sounds good yeah
sounds good right
decisive Victory decisive Victory is
when in war or business or argument or
life or a game one team or one side or
one party or one individual achieves
clear and overwhelming
Victory it leaves no doubt as to who the
winner
is it can create a shift in the balance
of power
right so it sounds really
good and you think I'd be fired up just
to tell everyone you need to go get your
decisive
Victory
but I'm actually talking about this not
to tell you to go and achieve a decisive
Victory I'm I'm actually going to tell
you to be careful of going through life
looking to score decisive
victories
because they can cause problems
there's some things to
think let's say you're doing Jiu-Jitsu M
let's face it in Jiu-Jitsu there's such
a thing as a decisive Victory it's
called a submission right when you get
submission it's a decisive victory yeah
right you won you submitted the
person but if you're looking for
that too much can cause you to take risk
that's
unnecessary now look listen I'm the guy
we're the guy that's our thing we come
from the dean list
Dean list going for submissions that's
how we train all the time but if you're
in a life or death situation and you
decide oh I'm going to go for this
submission
here you might be going for something
and taking risk that you shouldn't be
taking or if you're in a tournament you
might take a risk that you shouldn't be
taking so be careful on giving up
position same thing in business you
might oh we we're going to crush the
we're going to crush our competitor so
you do some invest in some over-the-top
investment capital investment on some
thing to try and shut them down all of a
sudden you spent too much you leverage
too much you gave up your
position
so going for a decisive Victory can
cause you to take too much risk it can
also escalate the
conflict because as soon as you start
getting hyper aggressive the other
side's going to dig in they're going to
start answering back that aggression now
all of a sudden what may not have been
that big of a deal that wouldn't have
cost you a bunch of a bunch of resources
all of a sudden now it's going to cost
you a bunch of resources
MH because the other side digs in when
you get
aggressive I mean even in a street
fight like you go to really hurt someone
they pull out a gun and shoot you like
that's what happens so you escalate
things look you get in going for the
decisive Victory you're hurting
relationships this is like in an
argument type thing when I get to prove
Eko
wrong cool I've totally made Ekko look
stupid in that big meeting now Echo
actually doesn't like me
anymore it's like that old uh topic of
winning an argument with your spouse
right oh it's great you won the argument
good job decisive Victory actually made
your wife feel a little bit dumb oh
that's great good job Terrible by the
way that happens with your your kids too
by the way kids become resentful cuz
you're actually bullying like if you're
arguing with your kids about something
and you score a decisive Victory you're
actually bullying
them so don't do that you're going to
cause unnecessary casualties right what
kind of damage are you doing when you're
going for a decisive
Victory it be Beyond relationships which
we we just talked about but even in a in
a business like even if I get the
decisive Victory but I've wasted all my
money or I've burned out my
team like I'm going to cause some
unnecessary
casualties what about my
focus cuz guess what when you start
focusing on a decisive Victory well this
happens all you know when this happens
in MMA going for The Knockout and you
see someone they're just trying to get
the knockout trying to get the knockout
trying to get the knockout trying to get
the knockout they're Swinging with all
their might they're telegraphing their
moves and they're not seeing that
they're getting touched up at the then
that the judges are scoring those
touched UPS or the that that opponent's
getting that easy takedown at the end of
every round yeah and all a sudden they
win 3027 they got a taked down in every
round showed the positional domination
there's only 30 seconds left but that's
how you win an MMA fight hit a takedown
with 30 seconds left do okay on the
standup and then just take a guy down
and control him for the last minute 30
seconds
and you win but what happens is when you
have somebody that is trying for a
decisive Victory it happens too with
submissions yeah oh I'm trying to get
that submission I'm going to exert all
my energy on this Guillotine choke and
then Ekko pops his head out I'm
Gass y it's true fake story not
true hypothetical but but you see what
I'm saying what's the
tradeoff what's the tra that's that's
something to think about when you're
going for a decisive Victory what is the
tradeoff m you know oh I'm going to I'm
going to get 600 lb deadlift cool
decisive victory over the deadlift how's
your Four Mile time run how many
pull-ups are you doing you see what I'm
saying yeah like you're you're there's
going to be a tradeoff yeah oh you're
going to put all your money into
crushing that competitor in one line of
business cool what about your other
lines of
business so what's the trade-off
you need to think about
that is there another way to win that's
win-win actually which is
weird isn't it weird to think of hey
Ekko and I are competitors and I want to
I want to defeat him I want a decisive
Victory and instead I go you know what
is there a way that ekko's company and
my company can actually work together
and we can both win and maybe I win a
little bit less but I can also help Bea
win and then all of a sudden we have a
good
relationship maybe in two years we merge
our companies to become the dominant
Force as opposed to me winning a
decisive victory over you you hobble
away you go and join another company you
give them your your
IP they have the money to invest in it
they build it and they take me over
right I blew it it isn't it kind of a
good thing if I can look for a
win-win or negot iting for something you
know what how about I figure out how you
can win
too and guess what what's driving a lot
of these decisive
victories is our ego the ego loves the
decisive Victory the ego is the most
decisive Victory seeking being on the
planet it wants to win and then it wants
to raise its arms and yell at the camera
at close range like they do in UFC like
ah
that's what your ego wants to do the ego
I brought this up I don't think you you
may not know this
yet was on a debrief podcast I don't
know if it's come out yet debrief the
ego is a short-term tactical thinker
yeah
the the ego is not a long-term strategic
thinker
so let's think strategic how can I win
with minimal
resources how can I win with minimal
effort that's Jiu-Jitsu by the way right
that's what Jiu-Jitsu is supposed to
be efficiency Judo that's what Judo is
supposed to be efficiency I'm not going
to use a bunch of energy against you
you're you're protecting that arm you're
squeezing that arm you're making sure
it's you're not going to give me your
arm cool I just took your
neck how can I win again something to
pay attention to how can I win with the
least amount of negative
impact how can I look look ekko's got
his company I got my company sure I want
to destroy his company okay but is that
really
beneficial or can I or can I figure out
a way to defeat his company but still
allow him to exist in a way that's
positive for the whole
Market is there a way to win without
with
minimum negative impact which which
comes around to like is there a way to
win with what's the minim minimum force
required for
victory what's the minimum force
required for victory can I utilize the
minimum force instead of the maximum
Force that's what a decisive Victory
calls for it calls for maximum
Force what we want to do is figure out
often now look is there a time when you
need a decisive Victory don't get me
wrong don't get me wrong yes there is
you're about to get in a fight with four
different people you want a decisive
victory over the biggest one of them you
want to knock him out cold
that's what you want to do you got
somebody that messes with your
country you want to decisively show the
world that that was a big big
mistake somebody messes with your
company or with a people at your company
in some way you want to protect those
people you go after them yes you want a
decisive
Victory but most of the
time you should think if that's really
what the best outcome will be you should
really think through if that's what the
best outcome is going to be because
generally
speaking generally
speaking the decisive dominant crushing
Victory is not as good generally
speaking as a victory that was gained
with minimum
force generally speaking look are there
cases yes there
are are there certainly are there's
cases where you want everybody to
know but most of the
time majority of the time I'll say not
most but a majority of the
time think through what your options
are for a minimum force
Victory there you go yeah that long-term
strategy thing is is a you know
obviously you know I very much value
that especally nowadays so uh this
happens in wrestling MMA fighting all
this stuff where let's say we me and you
were we're going we're fighting for the
championship
me big fight whatever I lose to you
whatever decision whatever whatever now
the the short-term game is like oh let
me let me go train harder to maybe beat
him again right the long-term game is to
invite you into my training camp now we
can train together and of course we both
get better right but now I become better
I can see like all your you know your
secrets your methods all this stuff that
not only apply to me competing against
you but me competing to everyone else or
with everyone else so it's like one of
those things where um yeah you'd never
think that you'd never think oh yeah
even if you beat somebody you'd never
think um oh yeah like let's invite him
into my gym I mean nowadays I guess ites
it definitely happens yeah it's actually
but the feeling you know that short-term
feeling like I want this guy in my gym
knowing watching me train knowing my
secrets like that seems like one of
those short-term ones that hits you
right away yeah that's like the old
school Jiu-Jitsu right very good
examples the old school Jiu-Jitsu yes
you couldn't train to someone else's
school yeah it's a crayon crayon yeah I
was actually talking to Miha today and
we're talking about you know old school
stories and stuff like that he was like
yeah I went to this other gym it was
interesting because they had this this
really rigid tradition and you couldn't
wear any of your stuff when you came in
you had to they had all these rigid
rules and stuff and then he's like but
when I rolled with them they were just
gaping holes in their game very
noticeable gaping holes just because
they they're so rigid in this kind of
training incestral thought patterns yeah
they don't they don't they don't
introduce like new stuff from you know
outside or whatever um yeah I guess a
little bit of attention but yeah it's
that that long-term thinking BR You' be
like wait what holes oh I'm not rigid to
nothing I want all you know yeah and the
the relationship things of like oh I'm
you know we're going to underbid this
this construction company and so you
underbid them you win the job decisive
Victory now you got an enemy now like
two months later you're calling them to
see if you could use their subcon their
freaking drywallers and they're like no
ain't happening yeah that's such a good
point let's think through things think
long term yeah think strategic that
argument one is a big one oh yeah when
you're getting into debates with your
friends and you're just like shooting
down their arguments making them feel
stupid like all this stuff especially in
front of people which kind of adds to
your your fuel you know other people
watching and then yeah they feel dumb or
insulted or whatever and bro no one's
trying to hang with you anymore you know
what's funny is like uh people don't
really argue with me very often yeah but
it's not because it's it's generally
because I'm not saying like well here's
what I think I don't go I'm not going at
somebody so if I'm not going at you I'm
just kind of telling you like oh did
what about this perspective and then
when you counter with your perspective
instead of me saying no that's wrong I
go oh yeah that's a good point there's
no real argument to be had right like is
it not possible that there's multiple
perspectives of the same item well yes
it is yeah
I'm I'm I understand that I understand
that if you know uh
uh I understand that there's ghee and no
gu Jiu-Jitsu yeah there's good points
for both of them yeah which one's better
yeah that depends on a lot of different
things I mean there's certainly people
that will argue which one is better yeah
for a variety of reasons sure I won't
I'm not going to argue it's there's very
few things if you try and argue with me
about something I want you to spend the
next week thinking about what to argue
with me about yeah think think where you
can get me to dig in on something like
unless you is is yeah like an Isis
fighter or you're a a
[Music]
communist which even a communist like if
you're sitting there talking to be like
well wouldn't it be good if
everyone that is a little excerpt of
what we are doing on the Joo underground
podcast so if you want to continue to
listen go to Jo underground.com And
subscribe cribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us strengthen this
Legion of Troopers that are in the game
with us so thank you it's Joo
underground.com it costs
$818 a month and if you can't afford to
support us we can still support you just
email assistance atjo under ground.com
and we'll get you taken care of until
then we will see you
mobilized
Underground